call of duty vanguard's multiplayer has
been revealed alan wake remastered has
been announced for this year mass effect
5 might be on unreal engine instead of
frostbite and halo infinite is making
changes to its radar after feedback from
the technical preview i'm persia and
you've made it to your gamespot news
update
sledgehammer games has officially
unveiled call of duty vanguard's
multiplayer mode 20 maps were announced
for launch and were showcased during the
reveal which is more maps than ever
before in franchise history a new
multiplayer mode for vanguard is patrol
which is a spin on a hardpoint except
the hardpoint moves across the map
classic call of duty modes like team
death kill confirm domination and my
personal favorite search and destroy
will also be in the game along with the
new competitive champion hill mode seen
in the playstation alpha something that
will come along with every map is
tactical destruction which is a new
feature in the cod franchise tactical
destruction is the ability to destroy
certain elements of the environment to
help flesh out enemies hiding behind
cover the caliber of your weapon will
affect how quickly and effectively
environments can be destroyed this of
course is just a fraction of what was
revealed for the multiplayer in cod
vanguard and we actually got a chance to
preview it so if you want to see even
more details and a full breakdown then
check out our preview that's live on our
channel right now
a remastered 4k version of 2010's alan
wake and its two expansions is on the
way from epic games according to a press
release the remaster will include the
core 2010 game plus the signal and the
rider dlc along with a new commentary
track from creative director sam lake
this also marks the first time the game
will be available for playstation owners
it was previously exclusive to xbox 360
and pc this feels like it could be
providing fans with a refresher course
on what happened in alan wake so they're
ready for remedy's next game in the
shared control allen wake universe
for those who don't know when control
was released it included hidden easter
eggs that suggested connection to alan
wake's unfinished story but control's
final story dlc made the connection
explicit control and alan wake exist in
the same universe and what's more the
stories are intricately connected
whatever comes next for control could
also include the future for alan wake
the remaster will launch this fall on pc
via the epic game store on ps4 ps5 xbox
one and xbox series xns so keep your
eyes peeled for that one
ea is reportedly considering using
unreal engine for mass effect 5 instead
of its own proprietary frostbite engine
an ea job listing for a technical
director for the game appeared and
states that the company is looking for
candidates with experience working with
unreal additionally it appears that ea
wants to explore other options with
visual technology during this new
generation and before full-scale
development for mass effect 5 reportedly
starts in 2023
ea could also be simply looking at
unreal to see what frostbite needs in
order to achieve what it wants from mass
effect 5. the original mass effect
trilogy games were built on unreal while
mass effect andromeda was built on
frostbite back in 2017 andromeda
launched to average reviews as well as a
myriad of technical issues at that time
frostbite was reportedly difficult to
work with so perhaps a potential change
to unreal engine for the next mass
effect game shouldn't be a surprise
after halo infinite's first beta the
team over at 343 has released another
in-depth blog update that shares some of
the feedback from the beta and how it's
being implemented including updates to
infinite's radar the halo infinite
multiplayer team said in the blog post
the combat sensor or radar that sits in
the bottom left of your hud followed a
different set of roles than previous
halo titles it only displayed enemies
when they were sprinting or shooting
which was more in line with halo 5's
threat tracker we knew that this
implementation was going to feel
different maybe even a little
contentious and that's why we wanted to
get feedback on it as soon as possible
in the tech preview the outcome of the
play testing is that 343 is going to
revert to a much more traditional radar
for halo infinite with the blog post
noting that most players preferred the
old style radar for social matches this
means all movement besides crouch
walking should appear on the radar the
post promises that these changes will be
ready for the next flight and if you
want to be a part of that halo infinite
flight before the game's release on
december 8th then make sure you head
over to halowaypoint.com because there's
still time to sign up for the next beta
using the halo insider program the next
flight is said to have a 4v4 arena and a
big team battle so you're not going to
want to miss that one
call of duty alan wake halo infinite and
just so many more games on the way what
are you guys excited for the most
are you hoping to see more remasters or
are you hoping to see more fresh stuff
let me know in the comments below and of
course thank you guys so much for tuning
in to another news update and we'll see
you next time
[Music]
you